enfin l'accueil chat cash and more les
blessures sont profondes
une dizaine d'années se sont écoulées
mais ce fonctionnaire est encore ébranlé
la plainte qu'il a déposée à la
commission canadienne des droits de la
personne et sans équivoque
il allègue avoir été victime de micro
agression de surveillance excessive et
de commentaires des gradins il y avait
des comportements qui était comme
allergique à ma présence au même micro
gérer à la seconde
jusqu'à demander qu'on coupe mappy ou
deux secondes trois secondes soit d un
iota depuis qu'elle s'implique dans son
syndicat
cette militante croule sous les
courriels de dénonciation et les appels
à l'aide
insultes harcèlement violences physiques
profilage racial frais à l'avancement
professionnel partout au canada des
fonctionnaires fédéraux affirment subir
de la discrimination raciale
rapidement c'est la santé mentale qui en
prend un coup
c'est très difficile de travailler
quelque part
on
ou tu es rejeté car l'engouement est ce
que tu dois abonnés la majorité n'ont
pas dénoncé
et ceux qui décident de porter plainte
s'embarque souvent dans un parcours du
combattant
la première étape convaincre son
syndicat je lui ai dit est ce que tu
vois ce qui entraîne de se passer ça
c'est la discrimination un métier s'il
te plaît palomo là ici donc je compense
je sais pas si c'est comme s'il ya c'est
un mot qui ne faut pas prononcer vo
cette source acquis radio canada a
accordé l'anonymat s'est battu jusqu'au
bout ou presque contre toute attente le
gouvernement fédéral lui en faire des
milliers de dollars en échange du
retrait de ces plaintes de
discrimination raciale et de son silence
en cas de bris de confidentialité
elle risque de perdre son emploi j'étais
très inconfortable
ces ententes confidentielles sont
immorales il met un prix sur le racisme
et ça laisse le système continué à
abuser d'autres personnes les sommes
offertes par le gouvernement dépasse
souvent le maximum de 40 mille dollars
pouvant être obtenues en compensation
après une audience devant le tribunal
c'est une façon d'acheter le silence lui
d'effacer une situation de
discrimination est un problème très
parfois très systémique serait lui aussi
l'imputabilité chacun des ministères
fédéraux ont travaillé les
fonctionnaires qui se sont confiés à
nous ont refusé pour des raisons de
confidentialité de commenter ces cas
précis et malgré nos demandes répétées
pour parler au président du conseil du
trésor
c'est son secrétaire parlementaire qui a
été délégué pour répondre à nos
questions et selon greg fergus ces
ententes confidentielles sont
acceptables mais seulement si elles sont
signées à la demande du plaignant
juste un compas pas faire une habitude
de cheveux on ne veut pas j'ai signalé
un problème utiliser l'argent pour les
principaux syndicats de fonctionnaires
eux reconnaissent qu'il faut mieux
outillés ceux qui appuient les victimes
de racisme
quant à l'association canadienne des
employés professionnels
son président soutient toutefois que le
syndicat est exempt de racisme
va falloir comment tout des rations pour
commencer à changer des choses
bernadette betty et porte parole d'une
action collective de 2 milliards 500
millions de dollars intentée par des
fonctionnaires noir ils sont maintenant
8 cents à dénoncer les pratiques
d'embauché de promotion discriminatoire
du gouvernement fédéral
le recours n'a toujours pas été autorisé
et le gouvernement n'a pas déposé de
défense
bernadette betty estime qu'il faudra un
véritable changement de culture pour
mettre fin au racisme systémique
elle allègue elle-même avoir subi de la
discrimination raciale en tant
qu'employé de la commission canadienne
des droits de la personne
selon elle même cette organisation
n'arrive pas à respecter son mandat
le problème c'est que les gens qui
analysent ces plaintes club et sont pas
sensibles à ça ou ou et quelques
mineures et que j'ai vécu du racisme
on va les pâtes ont l'expérience en
maintenant maintenant on sait dans
s'attaque là nous avons commencé à
donner en déformation
nous savons qu'il ya des enjeux
importants
nous savons que c'est pas toujours
facile de détecter ce qu'on appelle une
odeur subtile de discrimination raciale
bernadette betty estime que chaque
fonctionnaire a aussi un rôle à jouer
pour changer les choses
il ya un travail individuel afin donc ce
travail là les gens ils sont pas encore
beaucoup de temps sont pas encore rendus
là
iron a demandé de retirer la plainte de
god loves goy fusil n'a pas été retenu
ces autres démarches sont restées vaines
mais il refuse de perdre espoir j'ai ce
faire il faut pas que les amateurs point
sur ma fille vient a commencé à vraiment
comme ça ne voit pas très souvent des
choses comme ça
[Musique]